I've talked a lot about what
fractional reserve banking is,
but I have kind of reserved
making any commentary on it,
and that's what I'm actually
going to do in this video.
So just as a bit of a review on
the whole banking playlist,
I started off with a
very simple example
of we're on an island.
Let's say you had all of the
gold on an island and you give
it to me for safekeeping.
So now, I have this asset called
gold, and let's say
it's 100 gold pieces
that you gave me.
And I also have a liability.
This is my primitive island
bank, and my liability is that
you could demand this gold from
me whenever you want, so
this is my liability.
If I were to draw your
balance sheet, this
would be your asset.
So this would be an
IOU to depositor.
So at any point in time, I've
told you, look, I have this
nice safe, this vault there,
but you can come to me any
time and take as much of
your gold as you want.
And we, of course, know from the
fractional reserve banking
playlist that there's a slight
discrepancy between what I
told you, the depositor, and the
reality of the situation,
because the first thing that I'm
going to do when you take
this is, you know, I've taken
your deposits and I could
charge you for keeping your
money with me, but I've come
up with a slightly sneakier
scheme, where I say, hey, I've
seen your behavior.
You never withdraw more than 10
gold pieces out at a time.
So what I do is I lend out all
but 10 of your gold pieces.
So we end up with
the situation.
I have an IOU to you of 100 gold
pieces like that, and I
take the other 90 gold pieces
and I lend it out to random
entrepreneurs on our island.
So loan to A and that
is loan to B.
And I think this is great,
because I obviously collect
interest from these guys, and
assuming that these guys don't
blow the money, I'll get all the
money back, so you'll get
all your money back and I'll get
some interest, and I can
say, hey, I'm keeping
your money for free.
You get safekeeping, and I
collect the interest on it,
and maybe that helps to fund
making the vault nice, and
everyone's happy.
But clearly here, there
is a discrepancy.
What did I tell you?
What did I tell you,
the depositor?
I told you that you can
withdraw 100 gold
pieces at any time.
Now, what is the reality?
The reality is you can withdraw
10 gold pieces at any
time, and clearly, this is-- I
don't know if you want to call
this a lie or not,
but this isn't
completely true right here.
And I know some of you might be
saying, hey, Sal, this is
kind of a very primitive example
of gold pieces, but
our current banking system
doesn't work quite like this.
And just to make sure that you
understand that the analogy
isn't completely off from our
current baking system, our
current banking system is more
like this: You have 10 gold
pieces that you give me.
I'll draw it here.
This is the modern
banking system.
What you do is you give me a
deposit of 10 gold pieces like
that, and so I say that,
yeah, sure, I
owe you 10 gold pieces.
So this is my IOU to you.
Everything looks nice and clean
right now, but what I
then do is then I issue checking
deposits to other
people, and my limit on how many
checking deposits I can
issue is based on the reserve
requirements and all of that.
But let's say I have to keep
at least 10% reserves, just
keep the math simple.
So what I do in our modern
system is I make a loan to B
like that and I gave B a
checking account that is
equivalent to your
checking account.
So this is an IOU to B.
So this is essentially a promise
to B that, look, this
is a checking account, and
any time you can come
and get this much.
Maybe this was 40, maybe
this is 50 gold pieces.
This means that you can come
at any time and get 40 gold
pieces from me.
But we know the reality that
people actually don't actually
get the gold pieces.
In our modern system, we're not
even dealing with gold.
This will be reserve currency,
but it's the same idea that
people are getting money that
really isn't necessarily in
the reserves.
And, of course, I'm going to
make another loan to person A,
and I'm just going to
create a checking
account deposit for them.
I'm just going to create an IOU
to A for 50, and the whole
reason why this works is because
people use these
checking account deposits
as a form of money.
When I write you a check,
notice what's happening.
I'm just transferring one of
these checking account
deposits from me to you without
any gold or without
any reserve currency actually
changing hands.
So that's how it works.
But if you look at these two
balance sheets, one is kind of
the primitive example.
On my island where I had 100
gold pieces and I lent
out 90, I owe 100.
I've told people, maybe it's
just one person, that hey, you
can come to me at any time and
get your 100 gold pieces, but
the reality is I've lent
all but 10 of it
out to other people.
Now what's the situation
in the modern?
Well, I've told people that
there's 100 gold pieces that
can come from me, right?
10 to the original depositor,
40 to this guy that I gave a
loan to, and another 50 to that
guy, but the reality is
that I only have 10 gold pieces
in my vault and my
other assets are just
loans to people.
So if you look at these two
balance sheets, you see that
they are equivalent.
I always like to start with this
one because this one at
least makes more sense.
If you were to just walk up to a
five-year-old and say, look,
this is what fractional reserve
banking is, this one
starts to seem even a little
bit even shadier, because
you're creating these loans and
you're creating these IOUs
out of thin air, but your end
result is that they're equally
shady because they both
have the same
resulting balance sheet.
So your next question is, hey
Sal, what's wrong with this?
And I could ask my son, once
he learns to talk, what's
wrong with this is that there's
a discrepancy between
what I told the depositor-- so
in this case, I told the
depositor you can withdraw 100
gold pieces at any time, when
the reality is they
can withdraw 10.
Here, I'm telling the depositor,
you can take your
money whenever, where the
reality in this modern system
is that you can demand
whenever-- and I would throw
an asterisk there-- as long as
no more than 10% ask for the
money at the same time.
Now, obviously, I think this
is-- everyone already becomes
a little uncomfortable when
you say this, but you say,
look, this is what our modern
financial system is based on
and what this allows is this
guy, this bank, however you
want to view it, is allowed to
be an intermediary between the
savers, the people who are
giving their deposits, and the
people who need to invest the
capital in building new
projects and whatever else.
And the counterargument to that
for someone who's against
fractional banking is there's
nothing to stop
you from doing this.
All you have to do is tell
this guy the truth.
What you do is, you do this
exact same scenario.
You don't tell him you
can withdraw 100 gold
pieces at any time.
You tell him you can withdraw 10
gold pieces at any time and
that maybe another 40 gold
pieces will be available
whenever this guy is supposed to
pay back his loan, maybe in
a year, and that the other 50
gold pieces would be available
whenever this guy pays
his loan back.
Maybe it's in two years.
So the question is why
doesn't this happen?
Well, the reality is because if
you told the depositor that
they can't have all of their
money on demand,
he'd say, OK, fine.
One, assuming that you're giving
these guys-- these are
legitimate people to give your
money to-- I want some of the
interest that you're taking
because you're just lending
out my money.
If you were to lock up your
money for longer, people would
want interest for this.
But when the bank is allowed
to kind of tell this
half-truth, they don't have to
give as much interest on it,
because when people say, oh, I
can get my money whenever I
want, they say, well, then I
don't need that much interest
on it, because it's on demand.
But the reality is they
can't get all of their
money at any time.
They can only get some
fraction of their
money at any time.
So the next thought might be,
OK, you're being a little bit
disingenuous when you tell the
depositor that it's on demand
and because you're being
disingenuous, you're allowed
to kind of not give them as
much interest as you would
have to give them if you told
them that their money is
locked up, but what's wrong
as long as you are a good
investor and that you put
this money to good use?
Doesn't the whole
world benefit?
And that might be true most of
the time, assuming everything
I just told you, but imagine
a situation where we have
multiple banks in
our universe.
Let me draw my multiple banks.
So this is bank one, I have bank
two, and then bank three.
And bank one and bank
two are very
honest and good investors.
And we all know it's very hard
to know who's a good or a bad
investor, especially when times
are good, because then
most loans tend to
come out good.
So they're good investors.
But bank three takes
on extra risk.
Let me write it down.
And what's their incentive
for taking extra risk?
Let's say that bank three is
willing to lend to people that
banks one and two weren't
willing to lend to.
So bank three's balance sheet
here, these loans, are going
to be riskier loans.
Now why would they do that?
Because when you give it to
riskier people, you're able to
take more interest from them.
So they take extra risk, which
leads to extra interest. And
actually, if you were to look at
these banks, you would say
that this guy's the most
profitable bank.
Even worse, because he's getting
extra interest, he can
actually share more of that
extra interest with their
depositors.
So you can give higher yielding
checking accounts, I
guess I could call it.
Higher interest on deposits.
So in this situation, the person
who's taking the most
risk is going to be the most
profitable and they're going
to give the higher interest
and that might actually
attract the most deposits,
right?
If all these guys look the same
to me, and we all know
it's very hard to know what
banks are actually doing with
their money, then I'll say,
hey, I'm going to give my
money to this guy right
over there.
But then what happens as
soon as things go bad?
As soon as the world gets a
little bit of difficult, this
extra risk actually starts
rearing its ugly head and then
this guy becomes insolvent.
So this guy's-- let me see if I
can draw his balance sheet.
His balance sheet will look
something like that.
He has a bunch of loans out.
He's got some reserves right
there and then he's got a
bunch of deposits that you or
I might have given him.
These are our IOUs to us.
These are his loans out.
As soon as things start going
bad, some of these loans are
going to go bad.
As soon as one of those loans
go bad, I'm going to hear
about it on the news, and I'm
going to run over to the bank,
and I'm going to say, let me get
my money back as quickly
as possible.
And let's say I'm the first
one there and I
get my money back.
They promised it to me.
So I withdraw my account right
there, and I get all my money
back, and I essentially
deplete the reserves.
Now the next guy's going
to come along.
This guy was a little bit of
a slower runner than me.
He comes to the bank, and he
says give me back my reserves.
And the bank says there
are no reserves.
And then this guy is mad.
He has no reserves.
And, of course, the whole time
this guy's assets are just
becoming worthless because he's
loaned it to people who
invested it badly.
And so you have all of these
people-- when he finds out
that this guy didn't get his
money, all of these people are
going to go there and demand
their money and the bank is
going to be insolvent.
It's going to be two things.
It's going to be illiquid
and insolvent.
And I've explained the
difference, but illiquid might
mean the loans might be good--
and actually I'll reiterate it
in this video-- but the loans
might be good, it just doesn't
have the cash.
Insolvent means that these loans
aren't good, that the
value of these loans aren't
equal to these deposits.
So I'll say that this risky
bank is insolvent.
Now, you might say these guys
right here deserve it.
They guys deserve what they got
because they were greedy.
They invested in this risky
bank that was doing shady
things just to get a
little bit higher
interest on their deposits.
But what happens when
this happens?
Well, you have these good banks
over here that maybe did
really conservative lending.
So this is what their balance
sheets-- maybe both of their
balance sheets look like this.
They have some reserves
right there.
They've made out some good loans
to good entrepreneurs
and then you have their
depositors.
But as soon as this guy finds
out about what happened at
that bank, he's like, things
are really bad.
Let me just be careful and go
to my bank-- let's say it's
this depositor right here-- and
take my money out and put
it into my mattress.
So he goes to the bank and
he's the first one there.
He's the fastest runner of
all of the depositors.
So he claims his deposit.
So his deposit, he
withdraws, and he
depletes all of the reserves.
Now, he wasn't the only
guy who was afraid.
This guy was afraid as well.
So he comes running to the bank,
and the bank now says,
gee, I know I made this promise
to you that you have
an on-demand account, but that
guy you saw leaving the bank
with the running shoes on, he
actually just took all of the
reserves, and I guess I have
to admit now that I lied to
you, that it isn't completely
on demand.
I actually loaned out the
rest of your money.
But I was a good banker.
These are actually good loans.
These loans are still worth
what they want.
If you just wait long enough,
you'll get your money back.
And, of course, this guy's
going to be not so happy
because he was lied to.
And that's not going
to be the only guy.
Slightly slower runners are
going to come there and also
demand their money.
And this is known
as a bank run.
Where because one maybe bad
apple in the system actually
is insolvent, everyone becomes
afraid and comes and says,
give me my money, and because
we have this fractional
reserve system, the
money isn't there.
It just will not be there
because 90% of it is lent out.
And so once this happens there,
then you're going to
have a run on bank two, and then
everyone is going to take
their money out of the
banking system.
So the whole banking system,
this situation right here
where the assets maybe still
are worth the same or more
than the liabilities, this guy's
still solvent, but he
doesn't have any money to pay
these on-demand accounts, so
this guy is running into
a liquidity problem.
He doesn't have the reserves,
and that's why we have the
whole Federal Reserve that's
a lender of last resort.
This guy can walk to the Federal
Reserve and say, hey,
I have some people knocking
on my door.
Give me some loans.
The Federal Reserve will lend
this guy some money, and, of
course, then this guy's going
to have another lender to it
called the Federal Reserve and
he can use this to pay off
these guys.
But that leaves another
question: How does the Federal
Reserve really know the
difference between this guy--
he might say, OK,
this guy's good.
Let me just lend to him to make
sure that he doesn't have
a liquidity problem.
How does the Federal Reserve
really know the difference
between this guy and this
guy right here?
This guy's going to also run
to the Federal Reserve.
Hey, Federal Reserve, these
loans are still good.
Just give me a loan so I can pay
these people right there.
So the Federal Reserve says,
hey, you look good.
You're a nice clean banker in a
nice, fancy building wearing
a Rolex on your arm.
You must be good for it.
So the Federal Reserve will also
lend this guy, and now
this guy also owes the Federal
Reserve some money.
We can already see that in
this fractional reserve
banking system, you have two
problems. You have an unstable
equilibrium, where one bad apple
can lead to a run on the
entire system.
And I'll talk about what's been
engineered to fix this
problem: essentially
banking insurance.
I'll probably wait for that
to the next video.
So this is the first
problem right here.
And then the second problem is
that it really becomes hard to
differentiate between the
good and bad banks.
I mean, it's not so hard to
differentiate at face-- well,
it is hard to differentiate at
first and becomes even harder
to differentiate when you
always have the Federal
Reserve willing to be a
lender of last resort.
And when I talk about the
Federal Reserve insurance,
that makes it even harder to
differentiate, and because
it's harder to differentiate,
there's a huge incentive for
banks to take on risk.
Because when times are good,
they'll make more money than
everyone else, and then when
times are bad, it's really
hard, that they'll all
suffer equally.
So in the video, I'll talk about
some of what has been
engineered to fix these problems
and see if they
actually make sense.